digamos que tenemos una masa que está
unida a un resorte horizontal y esta
masa se encuentra sobre una superficie
sin fricción si la masa se encuentra en
un punto en donde la longitud del
resorte se encuentra en reposo y si la
masa se encuentra en un punto en el
resorte se encuentra en su longitud
natural pues no se va a mover a ningún
lado ya que cuando un resorte se
encuentra en su longitud natural se
encuentra contento en su lugar en el
universo no va a querer moverse no va a
empujar no va a jalar ese resorte no
tendrá energía y va a estar como yo la
mayor parte de los días de verano y a
este punto en donde el resorte ni
empujan y jala y se encuentra en su
longitud natural si tenemos una masa que
está unida a un resorte horizontal este
punto también será su posición de
equilibrio
y la posición de equilibrio significa o
se refiere a que el punto en donde la
fuerza neta de esa masa es igual a cero
y este punto de equilibrio para la masa
significa que el resorte se encuentra en
su longitud natural porque pues porque
el resorte no va a estar ni empujando ni
jalando a esta masa se va a quedar
quieto si yo coloco esta masa en este
punto se va a quedar quietecita por
siempre y como esto sería aburrido vamos
a decir que tomamos esta masa y la
movemos a la derecha una distancia de y
con esto vamos a darle a este resorte
una energía potencial elástica y si
liberamos a esta masa de esta nueva
posición pues este resorte va a jalar a
esta masa hacia la izquierda entonces
esta masa va a atravesar el punto de
equilibrio con cierta rapidez cual será
esta rapidez pues podemos encontrarla
usando la conservación de la energía la
energía potencial inicial del resorte no
es difícil es un medio porque la
constante del resorte
multiplicada por d al cuadrado que es la
distancia que se estiró este resorte y
aquí no tendremos energía cinética
inicial ya que vamos a soltar esta masa
que estaba en reposo y conforme esta
masa vaya hacia la izquierda va a
comenzar a ganar energía cinética así
que esta energía potencial del resorte
se va a transformar en energía cinética
es un medio por la masa y cuando la masa
esté en este punto de equilibrio no
vamos a tener energía elástica el
resorte no tendrá energía
tendremos solamente la energía cinética
y nos quedará esta sencilla relación
toda la energía del resorte va a ser
igual a toda la energía cinética en la
posición de equilibrio y si despejamos
ve de esta masa en esta posición de
equilibrio va a ser igual a la raíz
cuadrada
de acá entre la masa por la distancia al
cuadrado podríamos quitar esta de de
aquí ya que tenemos de al cuadrado y se
le está sacando la raíz cuadrada pero
esta es la idea
esta es la rapidez que tendremos de esta
masa cuando pase por la posición de
equilibrio ahora déjenme preguntarles
algo qué pasaría si ahora tuviéramos un
resorte vertical del cual estuviera
colgando nuestra masa y digamos que
quiero jalarlo hacia abajo una distancia
de pues si la jalamos hacia abajo y la
soltamos cuando esta masa vuelva a pasar
por la posición de equilibrio su
velocidad también va a ser la raíz
cuadrada de k entre m d al cuadrado y
ustedes se pueden preguntar bueno será
otra velocidad que tenga aquí bueno la
constante del resorte va a ser la misma
aquí la distancia también entonces todo
esto también se va a cumplir y esto
debería sorprendernos
que en esta circunstancia no sólo
tenemos el resorte y la masa y la
distancia en la que la movemos como aquí
en este caso aunque tampoco tengo
fricción lo que sí tengo es la fuerza de
gravedad aquí no sólo tengo la energía
del resorte y la energía cinética sino
que también tengo mi fuerza de gravedad
conforme esto se vaya moviendo de abajo
hacia arriba también tendremos cambios
en la energía potencial gravitacional
así que porque no estamos tomando en
cuenta la energía potencial
gravitacional en esta fórmula porque no
la estamos tomando en cuenta en esta
ecuación de la conservación de la
energía pues justo esto es lo que les
voy a demostrar en este vídeo si ustedes
solo querían conocer la respuesta tengan
en cuenta que esta la pueden usar en
ambas circunstancias así que si no
quieren conocer más de esto estamos bien
con esta información se pueden quedar
pero yo les recomiendo que sigan viendo
todo el vídeo ya que el saber el por qué
no tomamos en cuenta está m&g en esta
conservación de la energía
ayudar a entender realmente qué
significa está de esta h y esta vez al
igual que comprender exactamente a qué
nos referimos con la posición de
equilibrio y esto nos va a ayudar
conceptualmente si es que se encuentra
en un problema que sea más complicado
así que vamos a probar porque puedo
ignorar esta m g por h aquí
aquí tengo un resorte solito que está
colgando del techo está acá es la
constante de este resorte y digamos que
es un resorte ligero ya que si fuera
pesado es posible que él solito
estuviera jalándose por su propio peso
hacia abajo así que este es un resorte
ligero que está colgando aquí
tranquilito y se encuentra en su
longitud natural no está empujando ni
está jalando se encuentra en reposo como
lo vemos aquí pero ahora le ponemos la
masa m aquí no estamos jalando ni
soltando la masa simplemente la estamos
conectando al resorte y estamos dejando
que cuelgue hasta que quede en reposo de
manera que quede en su posición de
equilibrio
esta sería la nueva posición de
esto de aquí sería la nueva posición de
equilibrio
en otras palabras este es el punto en
donde las fuerzas netas sobre la masa
van a ser igual a cero pero en esta
ocasión no se encuentra este punto en la
longitud natural del resorte como lo
teníamos en el resorte horizontal en
esta ocasión la posición de equilibrio
está desplazada una distancia a alejada
del punto natural de equilibrio del
resorte ya que ahora se encuentra
equilibrando la fuerza de gravedad en
otras palabras la fuerza del resorte
hacia arriba acá x menos la fuerza
gravitacional m por g tienen que ser
igual a cero para que esta masa pueda
estar en equilibrio incluso podemos
saber cuál es la distancia a en términos
de estas variables y ya que está x es la
distancia que se ha estirado el resorte
nos queda que x es igual a m por g entre
k que es la constante del resorte
entonces esta x va a ser igual a nuestra
esta es la distancia que se ha estirado
el resorte para llegar a la nueva
posición de equilibrio con la masa
conectada a él y esto es algo clave así
que vamos a tener en mente este
resultado de acá pero ahora yo les
pregunto si tomamos nuestra masa y la
jalamos hacia abajo de manera que ahora
de manera que ahora tenga esta posición
aquí las fuerzas no van a estar en
equilibrio en este caso la fuerza con la
que estoy jalando el resorte va a ser
mayor que la fuerza de gravedad y si yo
suelto esta masa va a regresar así esta
posición de equilibrio con cierta
velocidad va a pasar a este punto de
equilibrio y ahora aquí la fuerza del
resorte será menor que la fuerza de
gravedad lo que hará que en este caso
gane la gravedad y vaya de nuevo hacia
abajo y esto va a continuar de arriba
hacia abajo y nos podemos hacer la misma
pregunta que hicimos anteriormente si yo
hallo el resorte hacia esta posición ve
cuál será la velocidad a la que pasará
de regreso este resorte aquí cuando pase
por este punto de equilibrio y
nuevamente podemos usar la conservación
de la energía podemos decir que la
energía inicial de nuestro sistema va a
ser igual a la energía final de nuestro
sistema vamos a elegir como punto
inicial este de aquí en donde liberamos
nuestra masa del reposo cuando jalamos
está más a una distancia ve por debajo
de esta nueva posición de equilibrio y
nuestro punto final va a ser justamente
aquí donde tenemos nuestra nueva
posición de equilibrio ya que es en
donde queremos conocer la velocidad de
esta masa así que vamos a tratar de
conocer cuál es la energía inicial en
este sistema cuando jalamos esta masa
hacia abajo y estamos por liberarla y en
este punto si voy a soltar la masa esta
masa va a estar inicialmente en reposo
si está en reposo no va a tener
velocidad y si no tiene velocidad no va
a
la energía cinética así que no tendremos
energía cinética al inicio cuando
tenemos esta masa en reposo pero si
vamos a tener la energía potencial del
resorte y aquí vamos a tener bastante
energía potencial en el resorte no solo
voy a tener esta masa que voy a jalar
hacia abajo por debajo de esta nueva
posición de equilibrio una distancia vez
sino que además cuando teníamos esta
masa en reposo con el resorte en esta
nueva posición de equilibrio el resorte
de todas maneras ya se había estirado
una distancia
y cuando tenemos esta fórmula de un
medio por la constante del resorte por
la distancia que se ha estirado el
resorte va a ser la distancia total la
distancia total que se ha estirado el
resorte a partir de su longitud natural
va a ser a + b y además voy a elevar al
cuadrado todo este término y esta es
toda la energía potencial del resorte
que voy a tener en el sistema al inicio
y cuánta energía gravitacional voy a
tener aquí bueno yo aquí puedo
elegir cuál va a ser mi punto de
referencia para esta energía
gravitacional y muchas veces por
conveniencia se elige este punto hasta
abajo como referencia esta va a ser mi
línea de referencia para h igual a 0 y
todas las alturas las voy a medir a
partir de esta línea y eso lo podemos
hacer así ya que solo estamos
interesados en medir las diferencias de
la energía potencial gravitacional solo
hay que ser consistente siempre con
nuestra elección y con mi elección de
que h igual a 0 sea esta línea pues la
posición de mi masa al inicio va a ser 0
y por eso mi energía potencial
gravitacional mgh en este punto inicial
va a ser igual a 0 así que en términos
de la energía en este punto inicial esta
va a ser toda la energía que yo tengo y
esto va a ser igual a la energía final
del sistema así que me pregunto tengo
energía potencial del resorte en este
punto final y quizás ustedes me digan no
ya que esta posición final se encuentra
en la nueva posición de equilibrio
pero recuerden que esta nueva posición
de equilibrio está desplazada de la
longitud natural del resorte una
distancia así que aquí sí voy a tener
energía potencial del resorte y es un
medio por la constante del resorte
multiplicada por la distancia que se
estiró el resorte en esta nueva posición
que es ah y esto lo tengo que elevar al
cuadrado ya que es un medio por acá por
x al cuadrado y con respecto a la
energía cinética esta masa va a ganar
velocidad hacia arriba ya que la estoy
soltando y se va a acelerar hacia arriba
así que la energía cinética en este
punto va a ser un medio por la masa por
la velocidad al cuadrado y esta
velocidad es la que tiene esta masa
cuando está pasando por este nuevo punto
de equilibrio que es justamente lo que
queremos encontrar pero además voy a
tener energía potencial gravitacional y
establecimos nuestra h cero aquí de
manera que si la masa se encuentra en
esta referencia
su h será igual a 0 pero como la
soltamos y va hacia arriba ahora sí va a
tener energía potencial gravitacional
por lo que mi h va a ser igual a b
recuerden que tomamos esta masa y la
jalamos de manera que el resorte ahora
está en esta posición de su longitud + b
y de aquí lo soltamos entonces esta
distancia que está por arriba de nuestra
línea de referencia es b así que aquí
vamos a agregar m por g por esta
longitud que la movimos hacia abajo
y que ocasionó que ganara energía
potencial gravitacional y bueno yo aquí
quiero despejar mi incógnita d al
cuadrado pero pues tengo bastantes cosas
por ejemplo tengo este término al
cuadrado así que vamos a comenzar por
este aquí tengo este un medio por acá y
ahora tenemos este binomio al cuadrado
así que esto me va a dar el primer
término al cuadrado a al cuadrado más el
término cruzado multiplicado por 2 más 2
a volver más el cuadrado del segundo
término b al cuadrado esto es lo que
obtengo de elevar al cuadrado todo esto
de aquí y esto se comienza a ver algo
complicado pero no desesperen créanme
algo maravilloso está por suceder y esto
va a ser igual a todo lo que tengo en el
lado derecho
y del lado izquierdo me queda un medio
por acá por al cuadrado más un medio por
acá qué es esto multiplicado por este
término de acá 2a por ver más nuevamente
esto un medio de acá pero ahora por b al
cuadrado y podemos decir que todo esto
es igual a lo que tenemos del lado
derecho y aquí hay algunas cosas que
puedo cancelar por ejemplo tengo este un
medio acá al cuadrado en ambos lados de
la igualdad por lo que la puedo quitar
este un medio se va a cancelar con este
2 de aquí por lo que me va a quedar acá
ahora por b más un medio k por b al
cuadrado pero que se está acá por a
bueno si ustedes recuerdan tenemos aquí
está acá y esta si las multiplicamos es
como si multiplicamos ambos lados de
esta igualdad por acá por lo que esta
caja es igual a m por g este enunciado
representa mi posición de equilibrio así
que está cab ahora la puedo reemplazar
por
m porque y ustedes me pueden preguntar
bueno y a mí qué me sirve reemplazar
está acá por a por esta m por g que
multiplica a esta vez bueno porque ahora
este término se va a poder cancelar con
esta otra mgb de este otro lado así que
voy a tener que esto es igual a un medio
m por b al cuadrado más m g b y ahora
puedo cancelar este mgb con este otro
mgb es por eso que reemplazamos estos
términos con esto de acá para poder
cancelar los y ahora mágicamente nos
queda la misma relación que teníamos con
el resorte horizontal pero ahora medida
desde nuestra nueva posición de
equilibrio y esto es importante así que
permítanme volver a mencionar todo esto
cuando ustedes tienen estos problemas de
resortes verticales pueden resolverlos
de dos formas ustedes pueden medir el
desplazamiento del resorte a partir de
su longitud natural como lo hicimos aquí
en donde sumamos a más
ya que fue la distancia que se estiró el
resorte a partir de su longitud natural
hasta donde pusimos la masa pueden hacer
esto y además incluir la energía
potencial gravitacional y así obtener la
respuesta correcta o pueden hacerlo como
lo deducimos aquí ya que vimos que estos
términos siempre se cancelan solamente
medimos lo que se extiende el resorte a
partir de la nueva posición de
equilibrio y si lo hacemos entonces
podemos dejar afuera todos los términos
que tengan que ver con la energía
potencial gravitacional y seguiremos
teniendo la respuesta correcta pueden
ver a la gravedad como simplemente el
desplazamiento de la posición de
equilibrio la bajamos un poco y a partir
de aquí esta masa se comportaría como si
tuviéramos este resorte encima de una
superficie horizontal sin fricción y
esto nos funciona si consideramos
solamente el desplazamiento a partir de
esta nueva posición de equilibrio
en otras palabras si limpiamos todo esto
y nos quedamos con este problema y nos
dicen que una masa de 3 kilogramos está
colgando de un resorte cuya constante es
de 50 minutos por metro y esta línea de
acá representa la nueva posición de
equilibrio ya que en este punto nuestra
masa se encuentra en reposo y nosotros
jalamos esta masa desde esta posición de
equilibrio hacia abajo una distancia de
punto tres metros cuál será la velocidad
de esta masa cuando vuelva a pasar por
este punto de equilibrio pues lo que
vamos a hacer es aplicar lo que acabamos
de encontrar vamos a decir que un medio
por la constante acá que es cincuenta
newtons por metro
multiplicada por la distancia pero vamos
a considerar solamente la distancia que
cambia la masa a partir de esta nueva
posición de equilibrio así que aquí
solamente ponemos 0.3 metros al cuadrado
aquí no lo voy a preocupar de que el
resorte ya haya sido estirado
a esta nueva posición simplemente voy a
poner esta distancia que se estira a
partir de ese nuevo punto de equilibrio
y esto va a ser igual a la energía
cinética que tiene la masa en este nuevo
punto de equilibrio y sabemos que esta
masa es de 3 kilogramos por b al
cuadrado y aquí no voy a incluir
información sobre la energía potencial
gravitacional ya que estoy midiendo mi
desplazamiento a partir de la nueva
posición de equilibrio así que aquí no
me queda más que despejar me ve y si
resolvemos esto algebraica mente va a
quedar este un medio se cancela con este
otro en medio dividimos ambos lados
entre 3 y obtenemos la raíz cuadrada y
nos quedará que la masa cuando pasa por
este punto de equilibrio va a tener una
velocidad de 1.2 metros por segundo en
resumen aunque pareciera que los
resortes verticales son mucho más
difíciles que los resortes horizontales
ya que tenemos fuerzas gravitacionales y
energía potencial gravitacional
medimos el desplazamiento a partir de la
nueva posición de equilibrio en lugar de
tomarla a partir de la longitud natural
del resorte podremos usar la
conservación de la energía sin tener que
mencionar nada de la energía potencial
gravitacional